welcome everyone this screencast kicks
off our series on methods and metrics
the overarching goal of this series is
to help you work your way through your
project and make smart choices around
experiments and data and metrics and
everything else and also be a kind of
trusted companion and sounding board for
you as you confront really hard
decisions around doing this kind of
research
let's start with an overview of the
goals and the current issues
fundamentally we're trying to help you
with your projects this comes down to
things like managing data establishing
Baseline systems comparing models
optimizing models and maybe most
importantly navigating tricky situations
we can provide some high-level guidance
here and then you should look to your
Mentor from the teaching team to really
help you optimize these things and get
through the really hard parts
for Associated materials we have a big
Notebook on evaluation metrics that'll
allow you to get Hands-On with some of
the detailed technical things that I
give an overview of in these screencasts
there's also a really wonderful set of
pages embedded in the scikit site about
how to think about model evaluation in
AI more generally
and then we also have an extensive
notebook that allows you to get Hands-On
with the more methodological stuff that
we're going to talk about in The
Notebook substantiates with experiments
some of the things that I'll just offer
you as general lessons here and then
there are a few things that you could
check out in terms of reading although
honestly there is much less reading than
you would expect this might be a sign
that the field is still maturing for
fields in the hard sciences and the
behavioral sciences there would be
entire textbooks about methods and
metrics whereas for us we seem to have
an assumption that people will just pick
it up as they go uh I'm not sure that's
to the credit of the field but that is
the current situation and I guess the
thinking behind this unit is that we can
help somewhat provide some more
systematic guidance on all these really
crucial things that serve the
foundations of our field
I wanted to start by saying one really
important thing about how we think about
your projects the fundamental thing here
is that we will never evaluate your
project based on how good the results
are where we all know what good means it
means being at the top of the
leaderboard or something similar
I recognize that publication venues in
the field do this and the rationale
there is that they have additional
constraints on space and that leads them
to favor positive results for new
developments over negative results
as an aside I think we can all see that
this is a distorting effect on the
scientific literature and it absolutely
is ultimately hindering progress because
negative results can be so powerful and
useful in terms of instructing people
about where to invest their energy and
in particular where not to invest their
energy so this is a kind of sad
commentary but I'm just observing that
it's true and then fundamentally for our
course we are not subject to any
constraints real or imagined on what we
can publish so we can do the right and
good thing of valuing positive results
and negative results and everything in
between
what this means is you could be at the
top of the leaderboard according to your
own experimentation but if your report
is shallow and doesn't really explain
how that number got there or what the
thinking behind it was you won't do well
more importantly conversely you could
try something really creative and
ambitious it might fail but that could
be an outstanding contribution because
of how careful you were about the things
we actually care about which are the
appropriateness of the metrics the
strength of the methods and the extent
to which the paper is open and
clear-sighted about the limitations of
its findings this is a wonderful
movement in the field that we
increasingly emphasize finding the outer
limits of our ideas and describing those
limitations in our papers I would exhort
you to do similar things and I think
overall on average this kind of work is
going to lead you to more fruitful
systems more rewarding results and
higher quality papers
so I feel really good about this and we
can talk in the next unit about how to
navigate tricky things related to this
publication bias I think fundamentally
we can do right there as well and the
shift in perspective that you need to
take is to move away from papers that
are a competition favoring your chosen
system and toward papers that are simply
openly evaluating scientific hypotheses
and mustering as much evidence as
possible to inform those hypotheses and
once you move into those modes you're
not anymore thinking about how to pick a
winner but rather just thinking about
strength of evidence and the importance
of the hypotheses so we can get there
and everyone will be happier as a result
but it does require a shift in
perspective from the Norms that we often
hear about which are competition
oriented
four methods I've put this under the
heading how times have changed and
unfortunately I don't have very many
happy lessons to teach here let's rewind
the clock to around 2010. in that era
you could develop your complete system
on Tiny samples of your trained data
once you had it working you would do
regular cross validation using only the
train data nice pristine experimental
setting you would evaluate only very
occasionally on your held out devset
in an effort to avoid hill climbing on
that Dev set and ultimately overfitting
to it and that's why you would be
cautious there and then in the final
stages of your project you would do a
complete round of hyper perimeter tuning
using your Dev data you would select the
best model and you would run your final
test evaluation and report that number
more or less as is
that was 2010 there is something deeply
right about this as a scientific picture
for our field but unfortunately times
have changed in 2023 you could develop
your system on Tiny samples of your data
as before good
however for step two either there's no
training data for your task or cross
validation on it would cost twenty
thousand dollars and take six months so
already we are off course here in terms
of our ideal scientific picture
relatedly the dev set is frequently and
crucially important to optimization so
you have to keep fingers crossed that it
really is a superb proxy for tests
because after all you're going to orient
all of your optimization processes
toward this Dev set
and then finally for the final stage
either hyper parameter tuning would cost
a hundred thousand dollars and take ten
years or there are no hyper parameters
but test runs cost four thousand dollars
because you're calling an open AI model
or something like that
boy this looks untenable right what do
we do the core tenets of the previous
era remain sound as I said I like them
there's something really good about them
but we cannot enforce them enforcing
them has become impossible if we did
only the richest organizations could
follow them and that would restrict
participation in the field in a way that
would be terrible if you're creating a
ranked list you have to put broad
participation way above all of those
very pristine and idealized methods that
we used to be able to get away with back
when every model trained very quickly on
a consumer laptop
so what you have to do is articulate
your methods and the rationale behind
them including practical details like
resource constraints and heuristics that
you had to invoke
however two rules should main remain
absolutely fixed here I'm adamant about
this first you never do any model
selection even informally based on test
set evaluations I know there are people
violating this rule out there in the
field but don't follow that path it's
really important for us especially when
we think about the high stakes scenarios
that we could be deploying our systems
in to have pristine test evaluations
that give us an honest look about how
our systems will behave on unseen
examples and you compromise that
entirely the moment you choose a model
based on test set numbers
relatedly as you think about
constructing baselines and ablations and
comparisons with the literature you have
to strive to give all systems you
evaluate the best chance of success you
should never ever stack the deck in
favor of a system that you are
advocating for we all know it can be
done all these models have hyper
parameters and you could pick really bad
settings for models you disfavor and you
could work really hard to find Optimal
settings for models that you like about
in that way you would appear to have won
some kind of competition but you would
have compromised the very foundations of
your project
what you need to do instead is give
every system its best chance work really
hard to make all of them competitive the
result will be better science results
you can trust and ultimately you will go
farther in the field if you are rigorous
about this rule as well
that was it for methods for metrics I
can be more hopeful I have put this
under the heading how time should change
and I do feel like they are changing
very rapidly in a happy way
the overarching idea that we could have
in mind here is strathearn's law when a
measure becomes a Target it ceases to be
a good measure we have to beware
strathearn's law we have to be vigilant
and make sure we don't fall into the
strap
in this setting with this in mind I'm
always reminded of leaderboards you know
leaderboards are Central to the way the
Field Works we all think about them and
use them as markers of progress they do
have their good aspects right
leaderboards can be an objective basis
for comparison and that creates
opportunities for even wild seeming
ideas to get a hearing and Fields
without leaderboards very often these
wild ideas are rejected out of hand by
the community with no evaluation whereas
at least leaderboards give people in our
field a chance to participate that's the
good the bad though this can get really
bad with leaderboards we have a constant
conflation of Benchmark improvements
with actual progress when we know in
fact that the benchmarks might be
fallible relatedly we have this
conflation of benchmarks with empirical
domains people say things like OCR is
solved question answering is solved what
they really mean is that certain
benchmarks have been solved and we are
all aware by now know that those two
claims about the Benchmark and the
capability are radically different but
nonetheless people conflate them and
even in the way we talk I find we're
often guilty of this third thing here
which is conflating Benchmark
performance with the capability we see
that a system does well at question
answering for Squad and we assume it's a
good question answer even though we know
in our hearts that these two things are
very different
so that's the bad of leaderboards I
think what we should do moving forward
is think about how to bring in more of
the good more dimensions of good and
remove the dependence on these bad
assumptions that we often make
the fundamental issue here I would say
is that the metrics that you choose
including the ones that get embedded in
leaderboards are actually tied up with
the thing that you're trying to solve
and too often in the field we don't
actually make that connection so let me
offer you some scenarios and they should
get you thinking about how you would
approach this differently with different
metrics in mind suppose you're in a
scenario where missing a safety signal
costs lives and human review is feasible
what kind of metric would you favor for
a system
conversely suppose exemplars need to be
found in a massive data set again what
kind of metrics would you use to
evaluate systems in this kind of context
I think the metrics would be very
different from the first one in the
second scenario with the exemplars we
can afford to miss a lot of cases we
just need a few really good ones whereas
in the first scenario every missed case
costs lives and we have the opportunity
to do human review so obviously our
values are oriented differently
suppose specific mistakes are deal
breakers others hardly matter now you
want a metric that will give credit and
give demerits to different kinds of
mistakes and good predictions in
different ways to capture these
underlying ideals suppose cases need to
be prioritized you're not talking about
classification anymore you're talking
about ranking again you should have good
metrics for ranking
suppose the solution needs to work over
an aging cell network well now your
obsession with accuracy should kind of
go out the window in favor of systems
that can run on very constrained
Hardware low energy low power very fast
all of that stuff
suppose the solution cannot provide
worse service to specific groups well
standard machine learning models will
often favor majority groups we know this
and if your ultimate Allegiance is to
making sure that the system is Equitable
across groups you will have to change
your metrics from the norm and maybe
even your underlying practices around
optimization
suppose specific predictions need to be
absolutely blocked well now you're in a
totally different territory where some
kinds of error cost you infinitely
whereas others matter hardly at all
again a very different scenario from the
norm
in the field tragically the scientific
literature seems to offer one answer to
essentially every scenario which is that
you use F1 and related accuracy metrics
as your measure of system performance
you can see if you review this list that
F1 is not appropriate for any of these
scenarios F1 is just what we as
researchers choose when we have no
information about the application area
when we have information we should be
tailoring our metrics to those specific
scenarios it's just hardly ever done and
I worry that the lesson we project out
to the world is that you needn't bother
we don't do it and we are purported to
be experts so why would anyone else do
it even though as experts we can see
these different scenarios call for very
different metrics
relatedly if you do do a survey of the
scientific literature you find a kind of
overarching obsession on performance
accuracy F1 all of those things this is
really nicely supported by this lovely
and creative paper the values encoded in
machine learning research this is
birhani at all 2021. what I've done here
is distill their evidence down into a
kind of cartoonish picture that does I
think capture the essence of this I've
used font size to convey the values that
they find encoded in our literature and
in the largest font here unsurprisingly
is performance dominating every other
value that we might want reflected in
our research
kind of close behind in second place but
actually pretty distant is efficiency
then you get interpretability but notice
that's interpretability for researchers
we're probably guilty of that in this
class the interpretability work that we
talked about in the previous unit is
very focused on technical consumers
applicability robustness scalability
these are pretty well represented and
then I used a different and lighter font
to reflect things that are very distant
in this ranking interpretability but for
users Now beneficence privacy fairness
Justice we all recognize that these are
crucial aspects of successful NLP
systems but they are hardly ever
reflected in our practices around
hypotheses and system evaluation right
really if someone was just consuming our
literature what they would get out of it
is again just this obsession with
accuracy and related Notions of
performance
so we should push back we should Elevate
some of those other values in the form
of metrics that we use luckily there are
efforts to do this I've put this under
the heading of multi-dimensional
leaderboards I've been involved with one
effort dynaboard also Don bench and
explain aboard these are all efforts to
provide many more dimensions of
evaluation for our systems and get much
richer pictures of what's actually
happening in this context I would like
to mention Dyna scoring I think this is
a really powerful way to bring in
multiple metrics and even allow the
person behind the system to decide which
metrics to favor to what degree
and such a powerful metric that I've in
fact offered you a notebook that
implements Dyna scoring and offers you
some tips on how to use it so that you
too could explore using Dyna scoring to
synthesize across multiple things that
you measure let me give you a sense for
why this could be so powerful I have
here a real leaderboard for question
answering systems and the duberto model
is in first place according to my
dinosaur that dinosaur was created by
giving a lot of weight to Performance
and then equal weight to throughput
memory fairness and robustness
however with Dyna scoring I can adjust
those weights and so suppose I decide
that I really want a system that is
highly performant but also Fair
according to my fairness metric so I
adjust the Dyna scoring to put five
weight on fairness and I reduce
throughput memory and robustness
accordingly well now the previously
first place system is in second place
and Electra large has become the first
place system
and of course different weightings of
the different metrics that I have here
will adjust the ranking in other ways
and that shows you that there is no one
true ranking but rather rankings only
with respect to different priorities and
values and measurements that I take and
that is the essence of dinosauring to be
transparent about those values and also
to reflect them in good old-fashioned
leaderboards as we're doing here
[Music]
in this context when we talk about
evaluation and we talk about different
metrics people often say wait a second
this is all too technical too customized
too intricate what we should do is
something more like the Turing test
after all that was the ultimate test in
some sense the idea here is that a human
and a computer are interacting the human
is trying to figure out that it's a
computer and the computer is doing its
level best to fool that human and in
that way we're supposed to have a good
diagnosis diagnosis for General system
quality and intelligence and all those
other things
I just want to issue a cautionary note
here right the first touring test was
she is reported in sheber 1994 and in
that test Shakespeare expert Cynthia
clay was Thrice misclassified as a
computer on the grounds that no human
could know that much about Shakespeare
that's an instance of people not really
knowing what the Human Experience is
like in its full range and generality
conversely this is another comical story
in 2014 an AI a very simple one called
Eugene gustman passed the the Turing
test how did it do it well it did it by
adopting the personality of a 13 year
old boy when it was rude or appeared
distracted because it was confused about
what the human was trying to do people
just chalked that up to the fact that 13
year old boys are often kind of rude and
distracted and in that way it got a huge
pass
Google duplex is a real AI system a
sophisticated one and that is an AI that
routinely runs and wins Turing tests
with service workers it makes phone
calls and even though it announces
itself because it does this by law as an
AI right from the start of the
conversation people often lose track of
that information and believe that they
are talking with a computer
and relatedly now that we've moved into
this mode of doing a lot of natural
language generation we're all
discovering that people are not good at
distinguishing human written texts from
texts that come from our best large
language models so in this way
especially with the stories of duplex
and the llms we should reflect on the
fact that all of us are probably
constantly failing Turing tests in some
cases with sophisticated AIS but in some
cases with ones that are actually pretty
simple there are some cognitive biases
about social interaction that make this
not such a reliable test
there's another dimension to this that
we should think about in the context of
evaluation and that is how we estimate
Human Performance and my summary here is
that we estimate human performance by
forcing humans to do machine tasks and
then saying that that's how humans
actually perform Let me give you an
example in the context of natural
language inference let's imagine that
you're a crowd worker and you've been
asked to label premise hypothesis pairs
for whether or not they're neutral
entailment or contradiction and you get
a little training and after the training
you see okay a dog jumping and a dog
wearing a sweater those are neutral with
respect to each other because we don't
know from the jumping whether it's
wearing a sweater there's no
relationship
then you're given the example turtle and
linguist and you think well I can
imagine turtleing with somewhere in some
possible world but I was told this was a
common sense reasoning situation and so
I'll say contradiction because no actual
Turtles are linguists seems like a safe
assumption
but then you come to a photo of a
racehorse and a photo of an athlete and
you're asked to assign a label and you
think huh
I haven't really thought about this
before can a racehorse be an athlete
in general can animals be athletes
and you might decide that you have a
fixed view on this maybe you say of
course a racehorse could be an athlete
or of course not but the really
fundamental thing is that you might be
unsure what other people think about
this and in turn you might feel unsure
about what label you're supposed to
assign the human thing is to discuss and
debate to figure out why the question is
being asked and what people are thinking
about related to the issues but what we
do instead is block all of that
interaction and simply Force crowd
workers to choose a label and then we
penalize them in effect to the extent to
which they don't choose the label that
everyone else chose even though all of
us feel uncertainty here's an another
example a chef using a barbecue a person
using a machine is a barbecue machine I
think it probably depends on the
situation the goals the assumptions all
of that stuff the human thing is to
discuss those points of uncertainty and
then assign a label but we simply block
that when we do crowdsourcing
so now when you hear
an estimate of human performance you
should remember that the humans were
probably not allowed to do most human
things like say let's discuss this and
so human performance in these contexts
really means average performance of
harried crowd workers doing a machine
task repeatedly
we can all do that mental shorthand but
of course out in the world people hear
Human Performance and they think human
performance in the most significant
sense we should be aware that that's not
true and we should be pushing back
against the assumption that this is
actually what we mean when in fact this
is what we did
so what are we looking for with metrics
I would say that we're looking for
things that are kind of between standard
old evaluations
can a system perform more accurately on
a friendly test than human performing
that same machine task that is my kind
of cynical paraphrase of standard
evaluations
but we also don't want to swing to Canon
system perform like a human in
open-ended adversarial communication
that's the Turing test it's a very
particular thing and it's very thorny in
the middle there there's lots of
fruitful stuff
in the spirit of our previous units we
could ask can a system behave
systematically even if it's not accurate
that might be a system that is on its
way to being one we can trust even if
it's currently kind of not doing so well
can the system assess its own confidence
know when not to make a prediction our
systems in AI used to fail on every
unanticipated input now they give an
answer seemingly with confidence no
matter what you throw at them we need to
change that we need systems to withhold
information when they're just not sure
it's good information as an example and
maybe fundamentally
we should ask can a system make people
happier and more productive this would
move us far away from automatic
evaluation and toward things that were
more like human computer interaction
evaluations But ultimately I feel like
this is our goal and we might as well
just design evaluations that are
oriented to it
as I said I'm hopeful about all of this
I think that time should change and they
are changing assessment today or maybe
yesterday is one-dimensional accuracy
largely insensitive to context or use
case again F1 maybe the terms are set by
the research Community whether we know
it or not
the metrics are often opaque and the
assessments are often kind of hard to
understand deeply and they are tailored
to machine tasks right from the very
get-go in the way that they are
structured
I think assessment tomorrow or maybe
today depending on the work that you all
do could be high dimensional and fluid
it can be highly sensitive to context
and use case and the terms could be set
by the stakeholders the system designers
out in the world or better the people
who are using the system
ultimately the Judgment should be made
by users and the tasks that we're
talking about should be fundamentally
human tasks
we have entered into an era in which I
think we could start to implement all of
these Visionary items about how
assessment should work and so I would
encourage you all to think about how you
could push forward in these directions
with the research that you do for this
course